Transcriber: ÖZGE İŞBECER
Gözden geçirme: Emel Çırakoğlu
Bir varmış, bir yokmuş.
Bir varız.
Bir yokuz.
Peki yok olduğunuzda bir şansınız olsaydı
ve geriye dönüp bakabilseydiniz eğer
sizi tanıyan insanların
kalbinde ve zihninde
nasıl bir tat bırakmış olmayı isterdiniz,
hiç düşündünüz mü ?
İşte ben bırakmak istediğiniz aslında
bu tatla ilgileniyorum.
Benim işim birazcık bu.
Tabii ki varlığınız da varken.
Ben Dilara. Kişisel marka danışmanıyım.
Kurumsal eğitmenim, aynı zamanda
profesyonel koçluk yapıyorum ve
insan kaynakları danışmanlığı
da yapıyorum.
Tabi bunların yanında bir anneyim, eşim,
evladım, ablayım, arkadaşım.
Bunların her biri ve aslında
hepsinin toplamıyım.
Bugün bu sahneye çıkmadan önce sıfır
noktasını ilk duyduğumda tema olarak
uzunca bir süre düşündüm ve genellikle
sıfır noktası deyince de işte
biliyorsunuz hep böyle aslında bir şeyleri
sıfırdan almak, sıfırdan başlamak,
hayata karşı verilen mücadele ya da aşılan
zorluklar gibi şeyler gelir akla.
Ben size bugün aslında bunlardan
bahsetmeyeceğim.
Benim bahsedeceğim şey aslında
birazcık daha.
Farkındalık tarafı olacak.
Çünkü baktığımızda hepimiz
az önce benim bahsettiğim gibi birbirinden
farklı rollere sahibiz ve
aslında hepimiz her yeni güne
uyandığımızda her sabah hayatı
sıfır noktasından alarak başlıyoruz.
Peki bunun ne kadar farkındayız?
Yani karşıladığımız o yeni günü sıfır
noktasından alarak o gün içerisinde
gördüklerimizi, edindiğimiz tecrübeleri,
karşılaştıklarımızı ne kadar
hakkını vererek yaşıyoruz?
Sıfır noktasını ben birazcık daha bu
şekilde ele alıyorum ve az önce
sizlere bahsettiğim gibi birbirinden
farklı rollerimiz var.
Tıpkı bu salonda sizlerin de olduğu gibi.
Kendimden bir örnek vermek istiyorum.
Örnek veriyorum.
Ben bir gün şehir dışında Antalya’da,
Bursa’da, İzmir’de bir yerde eğitimde iken
fiziksel olarak ertesi gün kendimi
bir anda online’da eğitim ya da koçluk
veriyorken bulabiliyorum.
Bir sonraki gün insan kaynakları
danışmanlığı yaptığım yerdeyken
bir diğer günü de ailemle geçiriyorum.
Hatta bu roller arası geçiş aynı gün
içerisinde bile çok hızlı oluyor.
Şöyle ki:
Çok şık giyinmişim, hazırlıklı,
eğitime gidiyorum şıkır şıkır.
Çok da güzel bir eğitim günü geçmiş.
Her şey çok yolunda ve gayette
güzel bitmiş eğitim.
Eve geliyorsunuz tabir-i caizse
evde de aslında böyle alkışlarla
karşılaşacağınızı bekliyorsunuz
kapı açıldığında.
Ama işler pek öyle olmuyor.
Yani eve geldiğim anda çok değil yaklaşık
böyle bir 10-15 dakika sonra kendimi
bir anda böyle çorba karıştırıp bir
anda arka tarafta kızıma ödev
yaptırmaya çalışırken buluyorum.
Ve bu benim gerçeğim.
Benim hikayem.
Hepimizin kendine ait bir hikayesi var
ve aslında hepimiz kendi hikayesinin
kahramanı, kendi hikayemizin
kişisel markasıyız.
Hepinizin bir kişisel markası var.
Kişisel marka dediğimiz şey şu aslında.
Sizi siz yapan her şey; duruşunuzla,
görüntünüzle ve kurduğunuz iletişimle,
yaklaşımla, değerlerinizle, güçlü
yönlerinizle, gelişime açık yönlerinizle
itibarınızla sizi siz yapan
her şeyden bahsediyoruz.
Ben kişisel markayı birazcık daha
farklı şöyle de tarif ediyorum.
Aslında daha iyi insan olma yolunda
attığımız kendimizin daha iyi versiyonuna
ulaşmak için attığımız adımların toplamı
gibi de düşünebilirsiniz
kişisel marka dediğimiz kavramı.
bugün ben size işin o
birazcık daha görüntümüz
şöyle olmalı, duruşta beden dilinde
şunlara dikkat edelim gibi
şeylerden bahsetmeyeceğim.
Çünkü bunlar öğrenilebilir ve
geliştirilebilir şeyler.
Ben size çok daha önemli olduğuna
inandığım beş tane
temel özellikten bahsedeceğim.
Bu bahsedeceğim beş temel özellik benim
özellikle yıllar içerisinde bire bir
çalıştığım, eğitimlerde tanıştığım ya da
tanıdığım insanlardan yola çıkarak
edindiğim gözlemlerim ve bilgilerim
gibi de düşünebilirsiniz.
Başlayalım.
Birincisi merak.
Meraklı olmak.
Ama buradaki meraktan kastettiğimiz şey şu
değil: Aman arkadaşım kendine ne almış,
komşumun oğlu ne yapmış, kimler terfi
etmiş gibi bir meraktan bahsetmiyorum.
Burada meraktan bahsettiğim şey şu:
İçimizde aslında taşıdığımız, var olan
o saf ve çocuksu merak.
Yeni bir şey öğrendiğinizde ya da yeni
bir şey deneyimlediğinizde, yeni bir
projeye dahil olduğunuzda içimizdeki
o öğrenme isteği, o öğrenme hevesi.
Ya da birini dinlerken aslında o
karşımızdaki kişiye karşı
onu o salt dinleme hali.
Merakla yani bana ne anlatmak istiyor
şu an, ne anlatmaya çalışıyor,
ne hissediyor olabilir?
Bu çocuksu meraktan bahsediyorum.
Ve kişisel markasını başarılı şekilde
yöneten insanlara baktığımızda ise
gerçekten içlerinde o saf ve çocuksu
merağı taşıdıklarını görüyoruz.
İkinci maddemiz duygusal dayanıklılık.
Resilience dediğimiz kavram.
Son yıllarda sıkça
duyduğunuzu düşünüyorum.
Duygusal dayanıklılık kavramını.
Ne demek duygusal dayanıklılık
dediğimiz şey?
Aslında başımıza gelen zorlu durumlarla
sizi kaygılandıran bir şey olabilir,
öfkelendiren bir şey olabilir, strese
sokan bir şey olabilir.
Bununla başa çıkabilme becerimiz.
Kendinizle konuşabilme beceriniz
gibi de düşünebilirsiniz.
Ve çok önemli etkinliklerden bir
tanesi duygusal dayanıklılık.
Kişisel marka olmak için de
çok çok önemli.
Ki Dünya Ekonomik Forumun
‘İşlerin Geleceği’ araştırmasına
baktığımızda da 2025 yılına kadar en çok
aranılan beceriler arasında duygusal
dayanıklılık da gösteriliyor.
Ekranda da görüyorsunuz.
İlk on beceri arasında duygusal
dayanıklılık yer alıyor.
Tam da bu noktada sizi tanıştırmak
istediğim bir kişi daha var.
Adı Viktor Frankl.
Kendisi Avusturyalı bir psikiyatrist.
Anlam terapisini bulan kişi.
Aynı zamanda da çok meşhur olan
kült kitaplardan biridir.
İnsanın Anlam Arayışı kitabının da yazarı.
Viktor Frankl, Nazi döneminde toplama
kamplarında yaşamış, bunu tecrübe etmiş
birisi ve tahmin edersiniz ki çok kolay
bir ortamda yaşamıyor.
Gerçekten işkencelere maruz kalmış birisi
ve o dönemi sağ salim atlatıp oradan
kurtulan nadir insanlardan biri.
Ve bunu şuna bağlıyor aslında.
Sonrasında kendisiyle yapılan
röportajlardan yola çıkarak diyor ki
″Bir kere ben içinde bulunduğum durumu
olduğu gibi kabullendim.
Olumlusuyla, olumsuzuyla yaşadığım
durumu bir kere olduğum gibi
kabullenebildim.″
Yani bahsettiği şey şu aslında: ne
Polyannavari bir iyimserlik.
Her şey harika olacak.
Düzelecek de değil.
Ne de kendini birazcık daha kurban
dediğimiz pozisyona sokmak da değil.
Olanı olduğu gibi görmek.
Sonrasında da diyor ki,
″Yaşadığım durumdan bir anlam ve
bir ders çıkarmaya gayret ettim.″
Şöyle bir hayal kuruyor
o dönemde diyor ki
burada gördüğüm her şeyi bütün
tecrübelerimi aynı buradaki gibi böyle
konferans salonundaki insanların
karşısına çıkıp anlattığını hayal
ediyor ve bu hayale sıkı sıkıya
tutunuyor, pes etmiyor.
Ve bütün bu özelliklerinin sayesinde
az önce bahsettiğim gibi o toplama
kamplarından kurtulan az sayıda insandan
biri oluyor ve sonrasında da
anlam terapiyi geliştiriyor.
Yine kendi kişisel markanızı sıfır
noktasından inşa etmek istiyorsanız bence
sahip olunması gereken en önemli
yetkinliklerden bir tanesi de resilience
dediğimiz duygusal dayanıklılık kavramı.
Dördüncü bahsetmek istediğim kavram.
Üçüncü bahsetmek istediğim kavram
ise farklı bakabilmek.
Yani aslında yaşadığımız her olay ve durum
karşısında olaylara farklı bakış açısı
geliştirebilme becerisi ya da işte
gerektiği noktalarda konfor alanımızın
dışına çıkabilmek, risk alabilmek
gibi de düşünebilirsiniz.
Dick Fosbury desem.
Kimler tanır aranızda?
Var mı tanıyan, Dick Fosbury?
Ya da Fosbury flop tekniği desem.
Bir şeyler çağrışım yapıyor mu?
Dick Fosbury 1.93 boyunda ve gerçekten
sporla ilgilenen birisi.
Lise yıllarında basketbol takımına dahil
olmak istiyor fakat elemeleri geçemiyor,
başarısız bulunuyor.
Sonra Amerikan futbol takımına girmek
istiyor fakat o takıma da dahil olamıyor.
Sonra şansını yüksek atlama spor
dalında denemeye karar veriyor.
Burada da vasata yakın yani normal bir
başarı sergilediğini söyleyebiliriz.
Sonrasında 1968 Meksika Olimpiyatları’nda
öyle bir şey yapıyor ki
gerçekten
kendi adını tarihe yazdırıyor.
Fosbury flop tekniğini geliştiriyor.
Ne mi yapıyor?
Aslında şunu yapıyor.
Düz atlamak yerine tersten
atlamayı deniyor.
Bazen bu kadar basit aslında ve farklı
bakabilmek gerçekten kendi
kişisel markamızı ele alırken de
çok çok kıymetli.
Dördüncü maddemiz ise gayret.
Gerçekten kişisel markamızı inşa etmek
istiyorsak bunun yolu çok çalışmaktan,
sabretmekten ve pes etmemekten geçiyor.
10 bin saat kuralı.
Malcolm Gladwell’ın Outliers kitabında da
bahsettiği gibi bir alanda uzmanlaşmak
istiyorsanız ya da yaptığınız işin bilir
kişisi haline gelmek istiyorsanız diyor.
En az 10 bin saat çalışmaya
ihtiyacınız var.
Hatta şu anda hepimizin bildiği, başarılı
olarak nitelendirdiğimiz birçok kişi bu
10 bin saat kuralıyla başarılı
olmuş insanlar.
Steve Jobs’ın dan Bill Gates’ine,
Mozart’dan Mimar Sinan’a
kadar bütün bu isimler
10 bin saat kuralına bağlı kalan
ve çok çalışan isimler.
Ve sonuncu kuralımız.
En önemliyi en sona bıraktım.
Gerçek olmak.
Tabi gerçek olmak derken işin
bir diğerleri kısmı var.
Yani diğerleriyle olan ilişkilerimizde
iletişimimizde, onlara karşı
gerçek olabilmek, sahici olabilmek.
Ama bence en önemli tarafı, en önemli
kısmı kendimize gerçek olabilmek.
Kendimize karşı sahici olabilmek.
Bunun çok çok önemli olduğunu düşünüyorum.
Yani ben ne istiyorum bu hayatta?
Ne istemiyorum?
Neleri seviyorum ya da neleri sevmiyorum?
Yapabileceklerimin ne kadar
farkındayım kısmı.
Burada da size tanıştırmak istediğim
bir model var aslında.
İkigai modeli.
İki, hayat demek gai, amaç demek.
Size hayat amacınızı buldurmaya
yönelik bir aslında felsefe.
Japonların uzun ve mutlu yaşama
sırrı diye de geçiyor.
Ben bu felsefeyle kurumsal hayatta
tanışırken, çalışırken karşılaştım.
Baktığınızda çok...
aslında benim açımdan çok sıkıntılı bir
süreç içinde değildim o dönemde.
Güzel bir firmada çalışıyordum, sevdiğim
bir işi yapıyordum ve yaptığım işten
bir para da kazanıyordum.
Ama dönüp kendi içime baktığımda
bir şeyler eksikti.
Tam böyle adını koyamıyordum ama,
böyle anlamlandıramadığım
bir şey vardı hayatımda eksik olan.
Tam da bu dönemde ikigai modeliyle
karşılaştım ve burada gördüğünüz aslında
soruları kendime sordum.
Yani bir kere dedim ki evet, ben
sevdiğim şeyi yapıyor muyum?
Evet yapıyorum.
Peki bunu iyi yapıyor muyum?
Yapıyorum.
Çünkü öncesinde farklı kurumsal
firmalarda da tecrübem vardı,
eğitim alanında.
Peki bundan para kazanıyor muyum?
Evet, para da kazanıyorum, eee?
İşte onun bir eee’si vardı.
Çünkü bu modeli sorguladığımda kendimde
şunu fark ettim. Ben daha fazlasını
yapabileceğime inanıyordum ve daha
fazla insana ulaşmak istiyordum.
Ve bugün bu noktada kendi ikigai’mi
açıklayacak olursam sizlere de
şöyle tarif edebilirim.
Benim ikigaim konferanslarda, eğitimlerde
ya da koçluklarda tanıştığım insanların
hayatına dokunarak ufak da olsa
bir katma değer yaratabilmek.
Siz de aslında bu soruları
kendinize sorarak kendi
ikigai’nizi keşfedebilirsiniz.
Ya da bugün bunun için
iyi bir başlangıç olabilir.
Şöyle bir özetleyecek olursak, aslında
kendi kişisel markamızı sıfır noktasından
almak istiyorsak, bir kere gerçekten
meraklı olmayı, duygusal açıdan
dayanıklı olmayı,
gayret etmeyi, farklı bakabilmeyi ve
gerçek olabilmeyi unutmamak gerekiyor.
Çünkü dediğim gibi işin kılık kıyafet
tarafı, duruş tarafı, beden dili tarafı
bunların hepsi öğrenilebilir
ve geliştirilebilir şeyler.
Ve dediğim gibi aslında uyandığımız andan
itibaren yani her sabah aslında bizim
için bir sıfır noktası, hepimiz için.
Ve bunun ne kadar farkındayız?
Her sabah uyandığımızda aslında
önümüzde iki tane seçenek var.
Ya uyuyup gördüğünüz rüyaya devam etmek ya
da uyanıp kendi rüyanızı peşine düşmek.
Teşekkürler.